wer weiß schon heute
morgen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind wir mal
wieder das neu beginnt
wir sind hier an der isar in münchen
sommer in der stadt wunderschön ist es
sieht es hier ist die floss länder
hier wird über 30 jahren geführt
wie lang die bälle eigene schuld da die
welle geht so langsam den endlos kanal
gibt für die surfer entdeckt wurde die
anfang wird 70 2012 ihr 40-jähriges
jubiläum die einwohner haben gesagt cool
macht es ruhig kein problem
die jungs damals aber niemanden gestört
im gegenteil das macht spaß zuzuschauen
so sind ja eine sehr friedliebende
naturnahe sportart und da gab es
eigentlich nie einwände ein brett so ein
bisschen schon echt ein bisschen fertig
aus reck-weltmeister fertig ausschaut
ist eigentlich hier so das wachs das
braucht man aber politik immer wieder
prozesse auch mal das braucht man damit
man nicht wegrutscht
was ist ein sodass abenteuerlichsten
dass du hier schon erlebt dass das noch
alles dran alles ganz gut bei mir alles
absolut
es ist absolut ungefährlich man braucht
ein bisschen balance gibt
vergleichbar mit snowboard fahren
skateboard bahn das ist sehr nahe dran
ist es halt sehr wacklig
du musst so ein bisschen üben mit das
ganze so in fleisch und blut und in
schritten mart übergegangen die bloße
haben uns noch nie gestört im gegenteil
das ganze existiert hier nur weil die
große wir sind
wir können super feiern wir können sie
hoffen wir können richtig party machen
und wenn ihr mal in münchen seit kommt
vorbei und dann stehen wir zusammen auf
dem fluss ich bin so froh dass ich kein
surfer können
sonst müsste ich jetzt ins kalte wasser
kann irgendwer von euch eigentlich
surfen
weißt du damals als ich noch klein war
war ich profi surfer so stand wurde von
dem hai angefallen und ab das surfbrett
an den nagel hängen